uh 20 more moves till the 50 movie will
come into place
Peter do you think Karthik Will Survive
another
thing he says the players are not
writing down he's asking the Arbiter
he's claimed something I think he's
checking on the 50 move rule yeah but
this is still too early because it was
move 95 I understand that he doesn't
know it yeah he uh have absolutely no
clue he just feels like for eternity
they are playing this position so what's
going on
I think it's two minutes extra for your
opponent
that's what's happening right now there
is a pen alty time for a wrong claim and
I doubt
it's going to be any less time for
Karthik but I think it's more time for
Hikaru that gets added on the clock
because Karthik claimed wrongly for the
50 move rule yeah but at the same time
he he now got some certainty yeah he
knows where he stands so that he still
needs to make 20 more moves which is
also good news that he knows that he has
to focus on the position
he gets the clarity of how much further
he needs to keep his nerves intact
and he makes a move we see Hikaru there
with extra additional time on the clock
yes but okay so far what Karthik has
shown in this match yeah Luke actually
check kind of
yeah that's it that's it
that's it voluntary goes into a
stalemate there wasn't much to be done
what a save by Karthik taking that a
draw again